It's clear that in terms of optimistic
positivity is a predictor of mortality.
It does predict mortality and it
predicts mortality when you control for
lots of different,
uh,
self reported health problems,
depression scales that have been
validated,
self reported health.
If you're interested in predicting
things from optimism or optimistic
positivity,
you want to look at what predicts it.
And that's what I was focusing on in
that first paper.
So we have three papers already started.
Basically we're looking at,
uh,
explicit measures of optimism as well as
these were using wording effects,
um,
to measure what we calling him.
Implicit measures of,
uh,
close to perceptual optimism and
pessimism.
That positive wording bias is a form of
optimism.
But if you're looking at the world in
more positive ways,
you're taking information in and you're
framing it in positive ways and you're
seeing it so you're reacting to it and
positive ways sometimes in the way that
you,
you don't even know that you're doing
right.
It's so subtle.
It's like a wording effect that you
couldn't say that you,
you know,
it's not like I'm asking you,
are you responding this way to these
words of that,
those ways,
that words,
we can detect it statistically over
people.
So when you're asking people to say
things about themselves on a survey,
for example,
you're asking them,
you know,
are you a good person?
Are you a competent person?
Um,
there's a whole series of questions you
can ask them.
Some of them will,
uh,
already positively some of them and
negatively.
And usually those wording,
uh,
those survey questions are,
used to,
uh,
to create scales of things like self
esteem,
self efficacy mastery.
There's a latent variable.
The idea is that there's something out
there.
It's latent and it explained some
variance in how people answer these
questions.
And we're putting that together with
some measures that acts.
Pete,
ask people about how optimistic they are
using language explicitly and saying
that together those things create this
phenomenon.
And we're saying that the phenomenon
goes deep,
uh,
to level of perception is itself a form
of,
uh,
of stratification.
If is there something about optimism
that's,
uh,
that's a resource that we can understand
as a psychological good,
like happiness,
right?
And so if it's stratified in the
population,
how is it an associated with other kinds
of stratification in column and,
and,
and so forth.
Education.
And so,
uh,
you know,
you saying,
well,
class,
the real interesting one is class,
right?
Everybody wants to know,
you know,
or
pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
You know,
think positively.
You'll be successful if you're
optimistic,
you will be successful.
Right?
But of course,
if it's successful,
you're gonna be optimistic.
So there's the reverse thing.
And so taking a class and looking at
classes,
really the really interesting part of
that I want to get to,
right.
And I think that's an interesting
question because there's a lot of theory
around sociology and emotions around,
uh,
the,
the idea that expectations are created,
the ability to meet expectations
generates energy.
That energy is what allows people to do
things.
It's something that emotional energy and
then,
uh,
it replicates itself.
Yeah.
So people are convinced to be
optimistic,
especially in the middle classes.
Okay.
And if they're not able to achieve those
expectations,
then that energy goes down and they
become dissatisfied.
There's some difference with cohorts.
And now I see with race difference,
I see cohort differences when you were
born.
And that makes sense in terms of things
like civil rights movement and what you
experienced in your life,
right?
And,
and,
and your hopes and dreams and,
and so forth.
So,
um,
the question I'm looking at now first,
of course,
is,
well,
you can't change,
you know,
not many.
There's not much way that your optimism
or pessimism going to change your gender
in a statistically significant way.
You know,
night change.
People can change their gender,
but it's not gonna Change your age.
It's not gonna Change your birth cohort
and,
you know,
race,
very small effects.
So I'm looking at those things that
influence,
that can be understood as causes of,
and they can't be reversed causality
first.
So that's what I've been doing.
And,
uh,
we ran these models and what do we see?
Well we did.
We saw that when you look at all these
things,
race,
birth,
cohort,
age and gender together,
that there's these curves and the curves
are interesting.
They start off with men being more
optimistic than women.
There's a convergence in midlife and
then a divergence.
Again,
we're metamor optimistic,
optimistic,
positivity,
higher optimistic positivity than women,
right?
We see your race trends.
Um,
and uh,
and those vary by cohort.
People born before 1932 whites.
I'm more optimistic than blacks for all
of these people.
Um,
optimism,
optimistic,
positivity declines with age,
right?
So we're seeing these trends over time,
declining with age,
but whites and more optimistic than
blocks and it's declining.
But for people born after 1932,
we see blacks having higher levels of
optimists.
Dick Putz,
these Americans,
right?
All US data,
uh,
high higher levels of optimistic
positivity than whites over the over age
period.
They are still declining.
That's optimistic positivity.
What about a pessimistic negativity,
right?
Uh,
blacks consistently higher than whites,
um,
in,
in this past pessimistic negativity
across cohorts.
So we can look at those things and say,
you know,
people who got more schooling past high
school,
you know,
they were optimistic when we first
measured them and,
and,
and they were more likely to get some
schooling and we can try to control for
other things and say it's,
it's really the optimism that's
influencing the schooling.
We could also try to say,
you know,
their,
their class background is influencing
their optimism and pessimism and I think
that's,
we have run better position to say
something about that.
We can look at them over 25 years.
We don't have what you were born with.
Right.
We don't have,
when you started off with,
right,
we do have what your parents,
what income your parents made,
you know,
what school you,
how much schooling you got and so forth.
I was thinking about this was that I
really came of age.
I be,
I graduated high school in 1976 as the
great society programs were in place,
there was really opportunity for people
who base,
I went to some of the high,
uh,
with that time it was called
Slummerville.
Leno wasn't very,
it's a place now that's very,
uh,
houses worth millions of dollars and so
forth.
But at that time,
it was a working class neighborhood.
Uh,
I wasn't a great students.
I got into university,
I did well in university because when we
option I saw was joining the air force
or the Army and,
uh,
nonprofit.
I'm a professor,
right?
So I was thinking about
my career in the con and in terms of,
uh,
this project and the opportunities I've
had.
And I mean,
I,
I'm a pessimistic person,
but I took advantage of the
opportunities because I saw that there
were doors.
The Way Society is structured is that
there's doors and if you can jump
through them,
it doesn't really matter what your skill
is,
that much,
their divisions are fine grained.
And if you can get through that door and
you get all sorts of resources and then
you're gonna get to the next level.
So I became an optimistic about
academia,
uh,
in a way that allowed me to continue to
put my nose to the grindstone and not to
think too much about it because the
resources were there.
Right.
I made the decision.
Yeah.
It,
but really the point I wanted to make
was these policies,
these programs,
kids don't have them anymore.
Like now I teach and uh,
and uh,
the kids see that the middle is getting
hollowed out.
Right.
And they're anxious.
Mental health problems and university
have gone through the roof,
right.
And,
uh,
university don't know how to do with it.
Um,
so,
and I can see why they have,
because the opportunities aren't there
and the kids realize that there's a
bifurcation,
right.
There's a make it a break.
Um,
so,
uh,
I look at myself,
I look at my own history and I say,
I,
I was the intel end of the baby boom.
And you know,
I profited economically,
uh,
in some way,
socially in some ways,
but you know,
in other ways,
maybe not.
Uh,
and so I look at these generational
differences now and I can understand now
you should,
going back to business,
right?
Going in,
somebody gets a job in the GIG economy,
right?
What's their mentality?
Like there's another gig down the road.
I'll make it work to the extent I can,
or,
or has it become like,
is this has to really work?
And if this doesn't work,
I'm screwed.
Right.
My career,
I don't really know.
I don't think anybody really knows
what's happening.
And these areas that you're interested
in terms of work,
you know,
and what the possibilities are,
are there,
there's some interesting questions that
you have to ask.